keeping up with technology is getting
harder and harder every time I make a
video so I thought maybe I'd start
something completely different
what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas and welcome back to the channel
thank you so much for joining me just a
couple of days out before Christmas if
you celebrate Merry Christmas to you all
if you don't I really hope you go out
and spend some time with your family
friends or loved ones and if for some
random chance you're out traveling the
world on your own well I hope you're
making some fantastic new experiences
and memories to last a lifetime so for
this video I want to create something a
little bit different that could
hopefully turn into its own little mini
series basically what I want to do is
recap all the latest and greatest tech
for the past four weeks or that
prospective month so today we're going
to be talking about all the latest and
greatest tech that's come out in
December 2019 I know for me keeping up
with technology trends is getting harder
and harder because so much tech gets
announced and by the end of the month
I've completely forgotten about
everything that's been released so to
make it easier on myself for these
little mini videos I'm hoping that I'm
gonna be able to take notes throughout
the whole month and then come back to
you guys at the end of the month with
some great content if this is something
that potentially interests you subscribe
buttons just down there smash it 2019
style so let's start with something
that's very expensive and looks like a
cheese grater you probably know what I'm
talking about
it's the Apple Mac Pro so the Apple Mac
Pro and the XT are screen started
shipping just last week and people have
already started reviewing these things
it is well and truly out of my budget
because it starts at ten thousand
Australian dollars or about six thousand
nine hundred USD and goes all the way up
to eighty seven thousand Australian
dollars or about sixty thousand USD for
a computer that doesn't count and screen
at all if you want the XDR screen it's
going to set you back
at least another eight and a half
dollars in Australian all the way up to
eleven thousand seven hundred if you
want the standard
is it for us prices this is about 8,000
total for screen and stand package that
brings us to almost $100,000 Australian
or almost 70,000 US for a computer don't
get me wrong this computer can do so
much more than my desktop can behind me
but for your average Joe this is well
and truly out of the budget talking
about things that are completely out of
my budget the cyber truck was also
announced in December 2019 if you're a
Tesla fan you know everything about this
truck if you're not a Tesla fan you've
probably heard a million and one things
because it looks completely different to
anything else in the market it only
costs about a hundred u.s. or 150
Australian to pre-order the cyber truck
but you're going to be expecting to pay
anywhere from about 50,000 Australian to
about 110,000 Australian for the top of
the range cyber truck this equates to
about 40,000 American to about 75,000
American in total for the top of the
range cyber truck including the
self-driving features now obviously this
truck is still not even in production
yet and will take about two years before
it hits its first customer the prices
are more than likely gonna change go up
go down who knows but with $100 or $150
deposit you can secure yours and make
sure you get it first if this is
something that interests you the one
problem with Tesla's though in Australia
is you probably don't realize it but
Australia is huge for example from where
I live to the capital city in my state
is 500 kilometers now the base model
Tesla cyber truck for whatever it was 56
57 thousand Australian dollars can't
even get me from home to the CBD one
charge of the Tesla cyber truck gets you
about 250 miles or 400 kilometres so I'd
need a bump up to the top of the range
spec model at a hundred and ten thousand
dollars to make it one trip from home to
the CVD
that's not return obviously the CBD has
some superchargers and has some power
stations along the way but everything in
between is pretty much countryside and
farms so in Australia having a base
model
Tesla is pretty much inconvenient always
around if you're looking to travel
anywhere outside of a major city when
you do travel what you do want to be
entertained though so the next thing on
my agenda here today is Facebook's
acquirement of the company called play
Giga if you don't know what played
review is that's all right neither did I
play Giga is basically exactly the same
company structure as what Google
launched a couple months ago called
stadia so play Giga and stadia is an
online cloud based gaming solution if
you want to use your mobile device your
TV your computer absolutely anything in
the world you can play games like you
used to play on xbox and playstation but
now you can play them on any device that
supports these platforms Facebook
acquired play Giga just a couple of days
ago for a hundred and twelve million
Australian dollars or 78 million USD
this is a pretty nice score for play
Giga but it also means that this space
is going to be booming and exploding in
the next couple of years
Google stadia still isn't available in
Australia but it is starting to roll out
in America so we're gonna start seeing
these cloud-based gaming systems really
take over what we know as your console
gaming today on a random side note if
you bought Facebook shares on the 21st
of December 2018 and sold them today
exactly one year later you would have
made a very nice 60 percent profit and
if you're thinking oh well Facebook just
keeps going up anyway you can buy that
any time well no back in December it was
at its lowest it's been in a while and
it just continued to go up from here it
just declined and declined before the
21st of December so if you were lucky
you would have picked a great date to
buy Facebook shares now if you use your
Google home your Amazon Alexa or any
other smart home device to tell you
share prices what your day looks like
what's the weather like in the morning
well it's about to get an even nicer
upgrade so Amazon Apple and Google have
actually decided that they're gonna
collaborate and create an open-source
standard for all things on the internet
basically what I'm trying to say here is
if you have a smart home and
smart-home device say you're lighting
and your Google home but usually it
isn't compatible moving forward in the
future all devices that are smart
devices are going to be compatible with
all the smart home speakers and smart
home tablets and other devices that work
with them so no longer you're gonna have
to pick up a box and go mmm yep it's
compatible with Google or yep it's
compatible with Amazon you're just gonna
be able to pick up its product and go
sweet I know it's gonna work this is a
great step for the future of AI and the
future of smart homes it means
everything will slowly get more and more
affordable so smart homes won't cost you
two three hundred thousand dollars to
have seabus integrated throughout your
whole home it's probably going to cost
you I don't know around 10 grand maybe
to have absolutely everything running on
your smart home device which is
something I definitely look forward to
this isn't a really attack thing it's
more of a futuristic kind of trend on
social media at the moment and if you've
been paying attention and dissent
between 19 you would have definitely
noticed baby yoda up popping up
everywhere for all my entrepreneur
friends out there I hope you've been
able to capitalize this on some way
shape or form Samsung was definitely one
of my smart entrepreneur friends out
there capitalizing on Star Wars and baby
Yoda trend if you've noticed they
recently released a Galaxy Note 10.1 but
on top of everything that comes standard
in the note 10 box you also get a custom
note 10 device you get a pair of custom
Galaxy buds a custom Star Wars case and
a collector's edition metal plaque so
basically for the same price of 2000
Australian dollars that you paid just
for the note 10 you get a whole bunch of
extra stuff for free you just kind of
have to deal with a custom painted Star
Wars phone if you hate it but you get
free galaxy buds so when Lewis for some
people win win folders and finally the
most important piece of tech in my
personal opinion that's come out in
December 2019 is the official
announcement of the quad-core snapdragon
865 chip if you aren't aware of what
this chip is and what it means it
basically means a huge leap in
technology especially in mobile phone
technology
so the Samsung S 11 is predicted to be
using this chip inside its devices this
chip is also going to implement some
amazing features into the Samsung device
and every phone that precedes it it has
the ability to record 8k and 4k footage
in 120 frames a second and slow-motion
video in 960 frames a second that's if
you know anything about cameras that's
beyond belief basically and that's all
from me guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this new little tech mini
series and recap of December 2019 if you
did smash that subscribe button
20:19 style have a Merry Christmas and
as always I'll see you next Monday